right so what I wanted to talk about
today is a particular issue that arises
in stoic philosophy and I'll tell you
why I'm just just a moment but just to
give you a sort of heads up that's it's
what we call this in accordance with
nature doctrine and I think it's
probably good if I give a very brief
summary first about stoicism because I
don't know that the intro students have
had much about that annoying classical
philosophy students have so stoicism is
one of the the main schools in ancient
philosophy you've got you know Platonism
when the academy Aristotle has his
Lyceum we have a few others and the
Stoics are named after a place called
the stoic which is a porch let's don't
point kool-aid where this guy's Zeno
began teaching and the handout that I
have for you has sort of the the
successions of these stoic philosophers
like many of the ancient schools we've
got one person in charge than another
person following and it went on for
quite a while
stoicism taught a number of doctrines
that were systematically connected with
each other
among them were this notion that we
talked about in the earlier class the
ethics class about virtue being the only
good vice being the only bad other
things being external most of the things
that are external or not really under
our control so we want to focus on that
isn't in our control but one of the
other ideas that the Stoics kept talking
about over and over and over again was
this being in accordance with nature or
acting or living in accordance with
nature and recently stoicism has seen
what you can describe understanding it
as an uptick in popularity we're
actually at the point in what we can
call the modern stoic movement where we
have an annual convention called stoic
on I was just there in Toronto this year
providing a workshop and meeting with
people and we have about 400 people for
that one there are stoic on X events
that happen this
four different continents we have a
online magazine stoicism today of which
I'm the editor and when it comes to
social media that I think the stoicism
face group so this is Facebook group is
now past thirty five thousand members so
there's a lot of people very interested
in it it's getting applied in businesses
it's getting applied in medical contexts
and psychotherapeutic context there's a
lot of people talking about it
and one of the things that I noticed as
somebody who does does research on this
is there's a lot of confusion about this
in accordance with nature business wanna
grab a handout to and so I thought it
could be useful you notice me recording
this for a wider audience to talk a
little bit about this I actually wrote
two pieces on this because I saw so much
confusion in the Stoicism Facebook group
people saying what is this you know it
means this it means this I was like well
we should probably should do some
writing about that and as I wrote those
two pieces by the time that I got to the
end of them I said well I think there's
actually a short book here so I'm at
work right now I took a detour from my
other project which is writing a book on
stoicism and anger I put that on hold
for the time being and I'm currently
writing a book on this question about
what does in accordance with with nature
mean probably self publish it so it can
be done you know very affordably and get
it out there much much quicker so this
was an idea living in accordance with
nature
that was very central to the classic
stomachs and they continually developed
it and expanded it it seems to have some
affinities and good what we might call
comparative possibilities with lots of
other wisdom traditions some of them
philosophical some of them religious
where where there's this notion of
aligning yourself with the world or the
environment or with with the nature of
things because it's been causing so much
controversy and confusion you know
it's something that that's well worth
talking about so I want to first to talk
about before we do a little bit of
discussion what we actually have about
this doctrine in stoic literature so
before going into that I want to say one
other thing too which is that the
majority of literature from classical
stoicism is lost we have these wonderful
catalogues of books in a source called
Diogenes lair teases lives of the
philosophers we've got almost no none of
those books not just for the Stoics even
for people like Aristotle Aristotle
wrote all these interesting sort of case
studies of you know constitutions we've
got one of them you wrote about 143 I
think we've got one when it comes to
stoic literature I would estimate that
we actually talked about this at Stowe
account
we probably possess anywhere from three
to ten percent of what was originally
written in the ancient world all the
rest of it is gone so what we do have is
helpful but it's not necessarily the
full picture we do know that the the
founder of stoicism Zeno wrote a book
specifically called on life according to
nature we may discover a manuscript of
that someday I'm not gonna hold my
breath waiting for it it would be
wonderful if we treat it but it's long
and we don't even have any useful
excerpts from it we know that he wrote
another book called
on choice or on human nature that would
have been nice to have as well but but
we don't have it so we have to
reconstruct it from other sources and
the main sources of the effort fall in
two different classes so a little bit of
a sort of intellectual history here we
have a few works by what we call late
stars these are people in the later
period of Stoicism living within the
Roman Empire and there's really three
main people Seneca so we have a lot of
stuff from you have these letters we
have a number
works that he's written actually that's
the bulk of the stomach literature that
we have
Epictetus who probably in some respects
more important than Seneca we only have
two things and they weren't actually
written by him they're written by his
his student who is a historian arias we
have his discourses and then we have his
enchiridion which some of you may
encountered the enchiridion is actually
some excerpts from the discourses and we
believe that we've lost half of the
discourses we think there were eight
books originally and then we have this
this book that's that's originally
entitled to myself by a Roman Emperor
Marcus Aurelius who's coming a little
bit later and you know it's nice it's
got you know twelve books or chapters in
it it's not very organized but really
not much of the stoic literature is and
it's helpful because it talks about this
but much of the time these guys are
actually instead of explaining the
doctrine they're referring to it and
using it we're not going into a lot of
detailed explanations systematically
about it because it's the sort of things
well everybody knows they had access to
all those books that we've lost so why
reinvent the wheel there is a side note
there actually was one stoic writer who
was faulted for for doing that the third
school aren't precipitous who was one of
the most prolific authors of antiquity
he wrote a lot of stuff but people were
like it's mostly excerpts and
explanations of other people's things so
we've got those guys right and we have a
few other supplemental texts that are
that are kind of nice there's there's
some fragments from a guy called
Heracles they found these you know in
the 1800s they managed to damage a lot
of the scrolls now we're slowly getting
to look at the ones that they didn't
completely destroy and then we have
other literature and I actually brought
one of these with us before I talk about
this one I'll mention I brought up
Diogenes lyrics as dodging easily
artists was a historians philosophy and
he's not really original
he's not particularly brilliant but it's
actually better than he wasn't because
he just sort of sticks to what the
people actually said as far as we can
tell and in his seventh book of the
lives of the philosophers we get the
wife of Zeno which contains a whole
discussion of what it is that the Stoics
think what it is that they talk so it's
like a summary sort of like a cliff
notes what you know the ancients
knowings had to say another really
important source is another person who's
not a stoic Diogenes was not a stoic and
that's Cicero who you may have heard of
Marcus Tullius Cicero it's very
important Roman politician took part in
the Civil War sided with Pompey against
Caesar so we picked the losing side
thought that Caesar was a terrible guy
I'm actually kind of convinced by his
reasons and Cicero wrote a lot of books
he was taking Greek philosophy and
putting it into a Latin language an
idiom and we get a lot of stoic
literature through Cicero even though he
himself is not a stoic he's attracted to
it in certain respects and then the
third one that's particularly nice is
this arias didymus epitome of stoic
ethics right and this is a nice tax
where you've got the Greek on one side
and the Latin on the other this is
actually probably written around the
time of Augustus so you know after
Julius Caesar because arias didn't mrs.
thought to have been a friend of
Augustus but it shows up in a much later
manuscript called this manuscript by you
honest Tobias who's writing who's
actually taking a lot of philosophical
texts during the beginning of the Dark
Ages and compiling them for his son for
his son's education and this made it in
and this is another sort of summary of
Stoics Aeneas so we've got two different
sets of texts we have the late Stoics
who for the most part aren't really
explaining the doctrine that much
they're referring to it all the time
this is why people reading them or like
what's this in accordance with nature
business I'm not sure I understand it
and then we have the the explanation
which are for the most part by people
who aren't Stoics and that's what we've
got to work with so I've talked at you
quite a bit at this point let's talk
about this this business of nature so
when you hear the words living in
accordance with nature what would that
mean to you for you know for you
the Stoics what do we mean by nature
today
we're living in accordance with that
yeah okay so what and what is human
nature like you know sometimes when
people do bad stuff we say well that's
just human nature you know and we're
like you know well these politicians
took bribes I mean we're here in
Illinois Wisconsin where things are a
little bit less corrupt you know and the
state's a little bit more functional and
we might you know why are things so
human nature you know people are
Schmucks right well that's not that's
not what the stalks they actually mean
that is a way in which we'd use the term
today all right where else do we mean by
nature I mean looking out the window and
seeing some of the fall foliage that's
the natural world right is it is it
possible to live in accordance with that
what would that mean what does that look
like you find it make yourself like a
mud hut maybe we've all your clothes out
of bark or you know wool that that comes
from the Sheep that you live with is
that more in accordance with nature and
what do we when we use this term all the
time this is all natural what do we mean
by that when we talk about like food
stuff yeah okay so hasn't been processed
much or we might distinguish between
genetic modification of things and them
you know this is non GMO food
I mean most all-natural food has been
processed in one way or another if
you're eating oatmeal oats doesn't come
right off of the plant the way you get
it in the box or in your little package
right unless you plant one of those oak
trees the Quaker wants right you just
pull the packet off but what do we mean
if we say you should live in accordance
with nature this is the puzzle that a
lot of people in these stoic forums are
winding up with because they see
Epictetus saying hey keep your your will
or your Faculty of choice in accordance
with nature in the like oh yeah
courtesan nature that's that sounds good
know what what is that exactly
and they get into big fights about this
what else what like wait what else might
me mean yeah well it could refer to sort
of a higher sense of divine nature and
living in accordance with the will of
divinity okay and the Stoics do talk
quite a bit about that yeah well I'm
going to reserve that one for a moment I
want to come back to this natural world
how do we live in accordance with that
yeah okay using only what you need
access materials science like a good
nature appreciate it yeah okay not for
example in summer maybe you don't need
the air conditioning out all the time
that could be living in accordance with
nature turning we don't have to turn the
heat on right now because it's not
really that cold we can put on a sweater
okay anybody else have any other ideas
so one thing I want to point out notice
that there's a lot of different meanings
that we might assign to nature and and
if we're not careful in distinguishing
these we're gonna blur them all together
that's that's typically not just with
this issue but a lot of other issues how
we get into intractable arguments with
each other like you know everybody's for
freedom right there's anybody against
freedom in here know what is freedom
well there's a whole bunch of different
meanings in freedom and if I talk about
freedom I might not have the same thing
in mind that yeah you do so we want to
look when it comes to the Stoics yeah
what they mean by what's in accordance
with nature because they get criticized
a lot by people who are like you know
these Stoics they talk about this living
in accordance with nature but that means
that you should behave this way because
I'm you know I know exactly what nature
means nature criticizes the Stoics for
for that sort of thing says they're a
bunch of frauds people who are into like
evolutionary biology and think that
there are hard-wired distinctions
between you know the male brain and the
female brain we'll try to read that into
stoicism and the Stoics actually said
that's not the case at all they think
that men and women have to cultivate the
same virtues and have the same
capacities so if we have if we have the
wrong conception of nature and I don't
mean wrong in the sense of factually
incorrect but just not mapping on to
what the storks are talking about we're
gonna get very mixed up when we look at
them so we probably want to see what
they actually have to say so one of the
things that we should keep in mind is
the Stoics actually had sort of a
development of their third doctrine and
I've given you that's why I have the
handout here you can sort of peg where
these people fit in Xena was the first
person apparently to talk about the end
of human life he has life in agreement
with nature which he says is the same as
a virtuous life a life of the virtues a
life cultivating good moral qualities
virtue being the goal towards its nature
guides us now this sounds quite a bit
different than you know looking at just
the outside world or thinking about like
human nature as being we're a bunch of
you know terrible people the idea is
that human beings we have certain
capacities for these types of
of moral goodness distinctive types that
we'll talk about in a moment there's
some development in the doctrine this is
again diogenes laërtius telling us he
says by the nature which our life ought
to be an accord cruciferous third guy in
there understands both the common nature
of the universe and the specific nature
of the human being whereas clancy's
second guy in there takes the nature of
the universe alone as that which should
be followed without adding the nature of
the part of the universe so if we don't
worry about the divine so much when we
think about the cosmos that we live in
the Stoics early on thought that we
could adapt ourselves to it we could
look at it we could figure out how it
works and we could say this is the right
way to live in accordance with it this
is a way that's out of whack with nature
or to use their terminology since
there's no out of whack in ancient texts
you know contrary to nature there's
there some additional developments that
areas didymus talks about which says
Zeno interpreted the goal to live an
agreement that is to live according to a
single line of reason and in harmony as
those who live in conflict are unhappy
so when we think about our lives and
we're we're unhappy and the conflicts
that we get in with other people they
usually stem from conflicts within
ourselves and we want to work through
those those conflicts those the after
again didymus says adding further detail
expressed that like like this to live in
agreement with nature assuming zero
statement was insufficient so CLE Anthes
added with nature and interpreted that
the goal is living in agreement with
nature cruciferous said to live in
accord with the experience of what
happens naturally Diogenes the fourth
guy to be circumspect in the selection
and rejection of things in a court of
nature now it's getting more and more
complicated right and finally we get
some ante Potter who says to live
continually selecting what is in
accordance with nature and rejecting
what is contrary to nature and you know
that's that's all very nice but it still
doesn't tell us exactly what living in
accordance with nature yes
the other thing I want to say before we
look at
a little bit more pulses the Stoics they
use a wide vocabulary for this a lot of
synonyms sometimes it's in agreement
homologous you know the word that we get
homology from and mathematics in
agreement in that way sometimes it's a
another way of expressing it Tata who's
seen which means along the lines of
nature they also talked about following
nature literally like following a line
participating in nature these are a lot
of losers the Greek terms the Latin
writers use yet other terms so let's
talk about living in accordance with the
whole since we made this distinction you
know the totality of nature and human
nature the Stoics although they did
recognize the divine they didn't think
of the divine as something outside of
the world they they believed that the
world itself was divine or at least the
the reason running throughout it the
logos running throughout the world and
so this entire physical world that we're
part of has its processes and we can
live in accordance with it or we can be
sort of you might say against it now we
can't really escape those processes but
what they mean is instead the way that
we worry n't our thoughts and our
feelings and our choices and the actions
so you know if I try to do things that
are actually against the way the
physical world works I can try it it's
not going to succeed right if I if I
decide that this should turn into a
cookie for me and I just really
concentrate on it because I want to have
a cookie after lunch that's not gonna
happen
right and if I invest you know my
emotions and wanting a cookie and this
is the way I'm gonna get a cookie rather
than like walking to the cafeteria and
buying the cookie I'm gonna be unhappy
better to recognize this as what it is
it's good for my glasses and that's
about it you know and the cookie will
happen later on its own terms there
there's a whole set of physical
processes by which I get a cookie this
is a silly example and
just made up here but but you see how
that works so the Stoics if we want to
talk about a neutral bigger picture
themes they talk about accepting feet
that's part of what it means to live in
accordance with nature as this totality
accepting the the situations that were
given doesn't mean that we're totally
passive
but we don't expect them to be other
than they are some of these are you
might say common sense right if I ever
it's we're close to winter now if I go
walking around you know tonight dress
like this what's gonna happen to me
pretty cold yeah I mean even today
without the sweater it's kind of cold
for me to expect things to be different
than that is irrational
what's rational is to learn how nature
actually works and then try to align
myself with it so this is physical
processes you know and a lot of this
stuff that we we don't really think
about until we get into situations that
bother us so for example living in
accordance with nature would mean
recognizing the vulnerability of things
that were fond of two natural processes
so you know this can what what can go
wrong with this it can tear I'm not
gonna terrorism I need this thing
there's all sorts of things
natural processes that can go wrong with
this anyone ever dropped one of these
into a sink or a bathtub or a toilet
what happens things
yeah and you know what the Apple even
knows but you know people will like go
and they like say I I don't know what
happened to they try the rice thing put
it in a dry rice and that'll suck though
it doesn't actually work they go to the
Apple store and they're like my phone
just stopped working and from the Apple
guys are like you know there's actually
a switch in here that flips when it gets
wet so we know you dropped it is
something we're not paying for it right
well that's just natural processes the
same thing can apply to people that we
care about
Epictetus says something very very well
that a lot of people view is very very
hard
she says when you kiss your spouse or
child remind yourself that they are
something mortal and then when they die
you're not gonna be so upset and that's
people are like whoa that's pretty harsh
you probably don't care about your your
wife or kid he starts out the sentence
by saying with those who you care about
this is what you ought to do so to adapt
ourselves to nature means to accept
things the way they really are and to go
with that Seneca has this wonderful line
he says that nature wishes our laws to
be identical with her own we would live
in us in a way that that is adapted to
how things really are
he also says that the Stoics also say
that you know there's laws too you might
say the ways our minds work if we choose
certain things other things will follow
and a lot of people get themselves in
trouble by wanting to choose certain
things that are gonna lead to other
things and saying no I didn't actually
choose this this other thing so what
would be a common example of that well
if you want people to enjoy your company
you can't be grouchy with them right
unless you find somebody who likes
grouchiness so if you wanted to grouchy
all the time then don't expect people to
like you to expect people to like you
and want to be grouchy all the time is
irrational it's it's going this is a
very common example of you know living
out of accord with nature so one of the
ways that that that Diogenes explains is
he says living virtuously is equivalent
to living in accordance with experience
of the actual course of nature our
individual natures are parts of the
nature of the whole universe this is why
the end may be defined as life in
accordance to the nature or in
accordance with their own human nature
as well as that of the universe so let's
talk about human nature you know we
mentioned that a lot of times we say oh
that's just human nature when people do
that claims that are bad right
that's not what the Stoics actually mean
the Stoics think that we have the
potentiality as rational creatures as
something different than the other
animals to live a better life and so to
live in accordance with nature is
something that we're we're probably not
all doing even those who you know are
studying or practicing stoicism are not
doing entirely because if you did you'd
be what the Starks called the sage the
wise person who is fully developed we're
more in process so we decide where we're
going to orient ourselves are we making
progress or we backsliding and falling
more towards other things so we could
think of this as as a kind of
transcendence or transformation of our
nature towards something better and the
Stoics begin a lot of their discussions
of this by talking about what is it we
have in common with other animals so
what is it that all animal life tries to
do in your experience yeah yes that's
one thing that's a little bit higher
they try to reproduce but you're totally
right about that and along with that
comes for certainty animals not just you
know making little versions of
themselves right maybe they make eggs
and eggs hatch or something like that
but they have some way of taking care of
their young you even like the wasp who
you know stings the spider lays all of
her eggs inside the spider and then you
know takes off and dies has provided for
further young right that's why they are
the some of those caterpillars wasps are
kind of predatory creatures and pay
respects we do this by raising our kids
hopefully right other animals do this
too in different ways
what's even lower than that though more
basic in order to reproduce there's
something else you have to do as a
precondition stay alive yeah every
animal attempts to preserve its own self
and not just that but
to flourish to do to do the things that
are going to make it have a fuller life
to be healthy and to try to avoid the
things that are gonna injure you this
this extends even to like your sense of
taste you know sweet things in general
shouldn't eat too many of them because
we live in a situation of artificial
abundance but sweet things in general
are wholesome to eat bitter things
generally don't eat them you know nature
designed us in such a way as to be able
to tell at least some of the time what's
gonna kill us and what's gonna die for
us now what is human nature and on top
of that the stoic state were rational
beings rational means we do
problem-solving we communicate with each
other we develop technology but it also
means that we live in society with each
other in ways that the animals don't I
mean some animals live in packs or you
know bees live in hives and things like
that but the bee hives never actually
get together and like work out the
problems with their neighbors you know
they just I mean if they have another
beehive that's a problem they sting them
all or do something I mean ants are
really interesting to observe in this
respect because they like colonize each
other and some enslave each other and
steal each other's young and do all
sorts of weird stuff but it's all
basically that chemical program yeah for
us a rational nature if we fully develop
it it means we can live in harmony with
each other that's a big challenge though
and the Stoics spent a lot of time
talking about how that might come about
if we don't do that
so we descend to the level of mere
animals Epictetus has a lot of wonderful
metaphors about us if you know if we if
we just follow our baser sexual and and
you know appetite instincts you know
eating food
we're like sheep then that's basically
what you know a sheep's great life
getting to eat what it wants to not
getting eaten by the wolf and getting to
reproduce wonderful life or if we're
predatory towards each other
we attack each other we're more like the
you know beasts of prey like the wolf or
the kind Fox or the lion or epictetus
likes also the snake and the wasp who
pesters other people and we don't want
to do that the stoic stress that every
human being can live and act in
accordance with nature at least to some
degree by developing our own human
nature this is going to require a lot of
other stuff along the way like
developing the virtues you know justice
temperance courage and wisdom it's going
to develop recognizing what our duties
to other people are and fulfilling those
duties it's gonna require working on
ourselves recognizing where we're not
doing as well as we should and where we
should work on ourselves more they also
have some very specific injunctions or
you know interpretations of this so for
example Missoni estroux 'this epic
Tina's teacher thought that farming was
probably the odd way of life that was
most in accordance with nature now he
was living in an agricultural society
but you know maybe there's something to
that do we do we think that you know
farmers are more connected with the
natural world than the rest of us living
in a very technological society I mean
done either garden you're probably not
all farming right but when you garden
you actually get your hands in the soil
you know something about plants and also
hopefully about animals as well well
Sonia's Rufus also talked about marriage
she thought that that was something in
accordance with nature so a lot of these
things are kind of culturally bound in
the late stoic so epictetus for example
says something that we probably won't
agree with now he was very rigid about
gender roles men should dress like men
looked like men women should dress like
women and look like women that's in
accordance with nature I think now we'd
probably be a bit more relaxed about
that he even went to like the extent of
you know facial hair I'd be a good guy
because I have beard you
are clearly out of a corded nature
you're shaming you too you've got a
little bit
you'd be okay although your beard is
kind of short you know I mean some of
this we probably want to say that's
that's culturally bound we're gonna
reject that but you know there's other
parts that we might want to think about
Seneca and Cicero will tell us for
example that anger
this is stoic stick a very hard line on
anger they said anger is never in
accordance with nature it could be
something natural that we feel but it's
not actually in accordance with a fully
developed human nature
Epictetus says another really interest
in conversation with a father where he
talks to this guy and he's you know the
guy came to visit them in that / - how's
married life going with you it's an
austere you know I've got this daughter
and she got sick and I was so overcome
by my affection for her that I had to
leave and I think this is that's kind of
weird
Ouisa so you love her so much that when
she got sick you could've stayed there
and the guy says yeah I mean that's the
way you know that's the way I felt
naturally that's what father's do you
know this is this is perfectly natural
an epic society let's think about this a
bit you certainly did something that you
think is natural but it's not something
good and I don't think you made her
situation any better by taking off when
she is sick and she could shoot him down
right the guy's worried about her dying
he's feeling anxiety and then emptiness
like the the clincher is he says what
her mom did her mom take off - what
about the nurse did her nurse take off I
think they'll offer don't they and then
though the absolute knockout blow is
what if you were sick would you want
people to like say oh I'm I have so much
natural affection for you that I'm not
going to stick around
care of you and the guy you know
realizes that he's wrong about this
developing this this sort of natural you
know familial affection or affection
towards friends or stuff like that that
would be within the scope of human
nature as well and so the storks are
good for showing us these sorts of
things they also talked about using
appearances using the way things appear
to us what impinges on us in accordance
with nature or against nature
so what would be an example of this well
I mentioned anger is a serious issue for
the Stoics when somebody cuts you off in
traffic does that tick you off I it
takes me off and I think that person is
a jerk
and sometimes I'm even you know I don't
follow the impulse anymore but I have
the impulse that I should like go around
cut them off too you know and then maybe
give them the finger when I do that or
honk my horn which is very risky
behavior really stupid you know
but why the hell would I think that
makes sense
all right the human I'm human nature
yeah well then it's not really human
nature it's a damage to human nature
it's an undeveloped human nature or less
developed human nature let's say if I if
I look at what's going on there and I
start practicing this like when I when I
get an impression that somebody cut me
off because they you know want to stick
it to me and I should act in this way I
can actually take a pause and say no
maybe I'm going to suspend my my
judgment here maybe I'm not going to go
along with that that's to use
appearances in accordance with nature we
can use external things in accordance
with furniture or out of a court with
nature we can use our wealth we can use
our social position we can use our
bodies areas didymus you know get all
sorts of examples of this going to
household management that are kind of
interesting I mentioned the natural
affection and how the action work
according to Epictetus and epictetus is
a really interesting guy
because he introduces another wrinkle
unlike the other Stoics Epictetus
focuses very heavily on what we have as
a Greek term Pro a racist some in some
of your translations it'll be translated
as will or coalition in other cases its
Faculty of choice in other cases its
moral purpose in some translations if it
changes from passes to passage which
makes it a little harder track but what
it is is the core of who you are
Epictetus tells people at a certain
point you are not your body you are not
your wealth you are your Faculty of
choice you are what you've made of
yourself and it constantly stresses the
need to you know either harmonize or
bring in accordance or act in accordance
to choose to make this this part of who
we are the ruling part in accordance
with nature and he thinks that we when
we start out we're not in accordance
with nature we're usually beset by all
sorts of problems and issues so to bring
this to a close and I'm gonna open this
up for questions and comments in just a
second I want to come back to the modern
stories and the controversy and
confusions about this so in the modern
story community there are some people
who will you know chime in often on
Facebook and say this term is just too
vague I don't know what it means to be
in accordance with nature you know does
that mean like I have to study physics
or biology or you know the doctor the
latest thing is from evolutionary theory
to make sense of this so some people are
confused for that reason other people
are importing ideas of nature then don't
map onto what the Stoics mean others
within the community are saying you know
there's a lot of cool stuff about
stoicism but we don't have to keep all
this stuff from the past I mean there's
a lot of things in what we call the
stoic physics that we don't buy for a
second like that you know the whole
world is ruled by some
cosmic mind that takes the form of fire
we don't know we don't do that sort of
stuff anymore
so maybe this Holi in accordance with
nature things not very helpful we'll get
rid of them others are saying you know
that it just means living rationally
so every time that we see living in
accordance of nature we can just
substitute living rationally and and
we're good
my answer is quite simply to say we know
what the Stoics mean by living in
accordance in nature it's in their
actual tests so if we go to those texts
and figure out what they actually mean
by it then we can decide whether we want
to keep the idea or not but that should
be the place where we begin with a
proper understanding of what they they
actually said and so there's a lot of
interesting controversy this is an
ongoing topic a live issue in a
community of people worldwide who are
arguing with each other about that
that's not something you can say about
everything you're studying in ancient
philosophy I think right so I thought
this might be a some interest now let's
look we can we get some time for Q&A
about eight minutes before I act I'll
let you guys go or comments suggestions
confusions whatever it is that you'd
like to bring up yeah oh this is a big
question right and the ancient Stoics
like some of them were like yeah there
were some sages like you know Socrates
was a sage you know but but nobody ever
wants to claim to be a sage because if
you do it of course you're not being
humble and there's a there's a question
still going on now who are the sages and
so I don't know anyone claims to be I
interact pretty regularly with people
who are kind of heavy hitters within the
modern stoic community and although I
would definitely say that there are some
of them who are was weighed further
along the line then than I am
they're not sages they they have foibles
and things like that but you might think
of it more like an ideal to approximate
tip you know and this is this is a
really interesting point Cicero again
who's not a stoic he talks about this a
lot in terms of like wealth people who
are virtuous we shouldn't have these we
shouldn't always refer to these super
high levels that nobody ever achieves
instead let's think about people that we
know who actually seem further along
than us but aren't completely perfect
because at least then we've got real
models that we can look that's probably
more helpful like if you've got a
grandpa who you're like grandpa is a
pretty good guy I mean every once in a
while he says an off-color remark and I
don't know why you got to fight with
this guy over here but for the most part
he seems like somebody worth emulating
that would be that would be like second
best age almost right but they with the
same to be doing is offering us a
picture of what it really means to be a
person aligned with nature you know or
the sage is the boss so you've got a
pain
I don't know how you could mix this into
an interest including any angle well
that was a joke but how we have to cuz
that was my question like so is the
stoic state sage like they won't prize
with their daughter you know I mean I
think that's people skepticism about
yeah well you know it's interesting
because on that issue I think a lot of
people confuse having an emotional
reaction with care you can care without
being the prey of your emotions you can
recognize that it sucks that you know
you've lost somebody who's close to you
and they lost their life without it
tearing me to pieces again I'll bring up
Cicero because this is one place where
Cicero does he likes the Stoics for a
lot of things in a book called Tuscan
dis potations where he's considering
their whole moral theory he says the
Stoics I think didn't they didn't get
this point right and Cicero's talking as
a father who did lose a daughter who
lost a daughter whom he was very very
close to and who writing philosophy is
actually a consolation for him a way of
him to get over the loss of his his
daughter so I think what Cicero says is
we can warn but in the appropriate words
so maybe that's what we have to do I
don't I don't go along with the Stoics
on the anger thing either I think there
are some cases where we probably should
get in if I see my kids getting bullied
you know anger might spur me to do the
right thing the Stoics did think that it
was bad across the board though so the
any of modern stomachs accept some
things and then reject other things you
know it's not a lockstep every single
thing because it's in the stoic text we
must follow it you know well it was
rational I mean if your kid gets sick
it's not rational like the kid actually
makes the decisions I know my reasons
really may be emotional I mean the issue
is how are the emotions excessive
stomachs are not unemotional they think
that some emotions are actually good we
should feel affection towards our
children for example but that doesn't
mean that we have to be overcome by
grief that doesn't the fact of being
overcome by grief that's not the test of
whether you care for them or not when I
started saying there's that it's new you
mentioned at the beginning so like an
Epictetus in particular but yeah there's
that one particular passage that's kind
of steep oh yeah then I suggested when I
first read that I was like this is
terrible
yeah and then he went on to say however
if he expresses the kind of sense what
you say there - it's the show of the
correct kind of emotion or something you
know he says two other things he says if
you're like if your neighbor is lost
kid don't hesitate to grieve with them
just don't grieve inwardly you know so
it's not like you're going it's not like
going to the funeral you wouldn't go
through the reception line and say not a
great loss to you you know that would be
totally kept another point he also says
so like when your neighbors is all upset
about something you're you're able to
say you know that's of course something
that's the way things go now when you
apply that to yourself it's not quite so
easy right so this is really a cognitive
strategy for dealing with the emotions
in a way that's not gonna be so unhappy
but again it's approximate to I don't
know a lot of people who are practicing
stoicism who never never get angry but
they certainly care wise so that's good
that's that's nice time
oh we have time for one more question
anybody
[Music]
you